as an adult watching Disney films you
have disturbing realizations that smash
your innocent childhood memories of the
movies hit the red button down below to
subscribe to our channel where are all
the mothers what have Snow White
Cinderella Ariel Belle Jasmine and Elsa
all got in common none of them have
mothers there's an evil stepmother
instead or the biological mom dies in
the beginning we're thinking of you
Bambi
it said Walt Disney was filled with
guilt over his own mother's death after
a faulty furnace killed her in the early
1940s in the house he had bought her
what's with all the evil women there are
plenty of Disney Princess films that
feature a woman as the villain
particularly the earliest movies Snow
White had to deal with the Evil Queen
Lady Tremaine and her daughters were
horrendous too Cinderella Aurora had
Maleficent to contend with Ariel was up
against Ursula Rapunzel was imprisoned
by Mother Gothel
as an adult he might start to wonder
about a certain level of misogyny we
don't want to see women against women
all the time
Belle's Stockholm Syndrome as kids
watching Beauty and the Beast we all
cheered when Belle fell in love with the
Beast but as adults with more knowledge
about unsettling psychological behavior
we probably consider the possibility
that Belle was suffering from Stockholm
Syndrome this is when the hostage
develops positive feelings toward their
captor but the movie screenwriter Linda
Woolverton
insists that's not so and the bell
transformed the Beast through love miss
Potts and chip sure will suspend our
disbelief that human servants were
turned into household objects in Beauty
and the Beast but as an adult you can't
help but be disturbed by the
unbelievable relationship between miss
Potts and chip
you can't tell so much when they're a
teapot and a cup but once they turn back
into people it's clear that miss Potts
is in her later years with that white
hair and matronly face how is she that
little boy's mother again grandmother
sure but mom
Cinderella's freaky feet as a child you
totally accept that the glass slipper
could only fit Cinderella but as an
adult you'll find yourself questioning
it first off Cinderella's feet were so
unusual no other woman in the entire
kingdom had the same sides what kind of
freaky feet are they and secondly if
those slippers fit like a glove
why oh why did one fall off when she ran
down this
there's the x-rated rescuers when you
watch the rescuers as a child you
wouldn't have noticed the x-rated
background during the sardine can scene
that's because the image of a topless
woman in a window wasn't visible at
normal speed but once it was discovered
on freeze-frame viewing Disney recalled
the home video of the 1977 movie in 1999
a spokesperson revealed the tampering
was done in post-production any adult
watching the film will now look for the
objectionable images the little mermaids
excited priest chances are your
attention was on Prince Eric and Vanessa
when you watch the wedding scene in The
Little Mermaid as a child but as a more
eagle-eyed adult you'll have zoomed in
on the priest instead and that's because
you would have spotted the disturbing
Columbus sticking out of his trousers
although was claimed it was just as me
and not his private Anatomy Disney did
change the scene in later releases of
the home video and edited out the bulge
I stride is named Tinker Bell and Peter
Pan's relationship watching Disney's
1953 version of Peter Pan as a child you
don't really think anything outward
about Peter Pan's relationship with
Tinker Bell but as an adult you realize
the relationship is a bit more
disturbing than just innocent platonic
friendship many have posited the theory
that tink was hot for Peter after all
she flew into a jealous rage over Wendy
and don't even get us started on the
scene when Peter spanked sting to get
the fairy dust out against her will the
crows in Dumbo Dumbo was released in
1941 when there was still segregation in
the US based on color so it seems in bad
taste to name the lead in the band of
crows Jim because that's blatantly Jim
Crow as in the racial segregation laws
before the civil rights movement as an
adult you'll find that makes for
disturbing viewing especially as Jim was
voiced by a white man talk and jive
erielle encourages disobedience parents
re watching The Little Mermaid probably
find themselves sympathizing with King
Triton Ariel goes to the surface when he
tells her not to and transforms into a
human despite his warnings and in the
end King Triton not only lets Ariel get
what she wants but helps her by giving
her legs kids cheer on Ariel when she
disobeys her father but adults realize
the movie sends a pretty bad message
ignore your parents and you'll end up
living happily ever after which
disturbing realizations have you had
watching Disney movies as an adult let
us know in the comments below and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up